joining us now from Capitol Hill alright
he's the star in today's hearings
Congressman Jim Jordan walk us through
this is madness that we're now living
through because they want us to ignore
the whistleblower not whistleblower
hearsay whistleblower who doesn't
qualify to be a whistleblower okay
that's number one and the contact with
the congenital Liars office you're right
I don't belittle in the country believes
the congenital liar nobody here's the
next step how do you ignore hunter and
Joe the real quid pro quo no you're
exactly right son and and this idea that
that Adams ships initially said the
whistleblower is going to testify and
now he says he's not because something
in between there what happened is the
whistleblower came to his office and we
suddenly found that out and now now he
says oh I don't even know who the
whistleblower is you know Jim I'm
watching you every day and I'm watching
all of these witnesses now we can go
through it all and but at the end of the
day aren't they all just commenting on
the same transcript yes there anybody
that has added any one witness that has
added a single thing beyond their own
interpretation of the transcript no no
the transcript speaks for itself and
several people said this you say it all
the time there are four fundamental
facts that will never change
have never change we'll never change
that's the funding slowly go one two
three and four go slow
we got the transcript that shows no
linkage no pressure no conditionality no
no do investigations to get the security
assistance dollars we have the two guys
who were on the call they both said
there's no conditionality there's no
linkage no pressure nothing and then we
have the fact that the Ukrainians didn't
know that aid had even been held up at
the time of the call and both our
witnesses today said it didn't they
didn't know until late August August
29th with the political article finally
the most important thing is the
Ukrainians didn't do anything no promise
no statement no investigation none of
that happened and the aid was released
so those facts will not change so they
got a status
turn it all up and have people say
someone said to someone else and Here I
am that's what their case is in as you
said the American people see through it
they know the facts on the president's
side and they know this process is
entirely unfair so how do you bifurcate
your brain as a Democrat which I'm
asking everybody how was it possible Joe
Biden is on tape fire the prosecutor why
would a vice president ever want to fire
a prosecutor in Ukraine stupid or you're
not getting or you're not getting the
money unless you do the act because he
was warned that the prosecutor was
investigating his son with zero
experience that's paid millions fire him
you get a billion don't fire him you
don't get a billion that sounds like a
shakedown bribery acquit a pro and quo
and they don't want us to bring that up
and this is what they are trying to say
happen with Donald Trump it is
breathtaking hypocrisy sir as serious
and the American people see it for what
it is here's the bottom line and mr.
gates that said this earlier this Sunday
Nancy Pelosi called President Trump and
impostor the Speaker of the House
calling the president of United States
an impostor that's what drives all this
the the Democrats have never accepted
the fact that 63 million Americans voted
for this guy and they want him to come
here and shake it up and he won an
electoral college landslide and they
don't care because they don't trust the
American people that's what this is
really all about and they're trying to
with an anonymous whistle blow with no
first-hand knowledge whose bias against
the president who worked with Joe Biden
who everyone knows who this guy is that
the atom ship knows him but he will tell
us they're trying to take out a
president 11 and a half months before
the next election and that's what drives
Americans crazy and you're right
and Don juniors right I think more
people are going to show up next
November and reelect the president in
another electoral college landslide you
Devin Ratcliffe oh the congresswoman
from New York has been great you guys
are crushing them every day I can't even
believe they want to continue continue
this ship show I can't believe it but
apparently they do congressman thank you
for what you did great job